Hi, my name's Greg Littlefield.
I'm an engineer at Workiva.
And today, I'm going to
be talking about getting
the most out of React in Dart.
For this presentation,
first I'm going
to go over a little
bit of background
around Workiva's use
of React and Dart,
and probably answer the question
that most of you have-- why
React and Dart.
Then I'm going to give
a quick intro to React,
to help those of you
not familiar with React
to get your feet
wet a little bit
and understand the concepts
I'll be going over.
Then I'm going to go over
the initial frustrations
that we encountered
when we first
started using React and Dart.
And finally the good
stuff-- solving those issues
and allieving those frustrations
using our new library
that we've called OverReact.
Great name, thank
our PM for that.
So first, background-- at
Workiva, our first application
was actually written
in Flash back in 2008.
Eventually we migrated to
writing newer applications
and new features in HTML5.
We started with Angular
1.0 and jQuery, and then
we eventually made
our way to React.
We really liked React.
We like the declarative
nature of rendering views.
We like a uni-directional
data flow.
And we started writing
a lot of UI in React.
Then we stumbled upon
Dart, and we really
liked the powerful
developer tools, how fast
we could develop with it.
We really wanted to put
the two together and get
the best of both worlds,
and be able to continue
taking advantage of all
of the existing React code
that we had written.
So we decided to use
React and Dart together.
A little bit of
context on me-- I'm
on the UI Platform
team at Workiva,
and we're tasked with supporting
a number of product teams--
alongside some other
platform teams--
and creating reusable
UI components for all
those product teams to use.
When we first started
writing React in Dart,
we found it kind of cumbersome.
A lot of the stuff that
I'll be talking about today,
like OverReact, is the result
of us improving that workflow
and building upon that.
So now a quick intro on React.
Quick show of hands, how
many of you have used React
or are familiar with
the basic tenets of it?
OK, so we got some, not
everyone, so that's cool.
Glad I have this section.
React is centered
around components.
There's DOM components
and custom components.
You can see this is a
JSX representation of it.
That's probably one of
the more popular syntaxes
to consume React components.
You can see, for
DOM components, it
looks pretty similar
to standard HTML.
You're passing in attributes,
or Key-value pairs,
and then you're nesting
components within each other.
For custom components, it
pretty much looks the same way.
You can nest components
within each other,
and you can specify
data by passing
in these Key-value pairs
that look like attributes.
Both forms eventually
render as HTML.
DOM components get
translated directly.
And then custom
components get translated
into the virtual DOM, and
then into rendered HTML.
So again, a custom component
encapsulates virtual DOM
rendering, and it can
also include UI behavior.
You can bind event handlers,
and do other things on it.
Then the data that's passed
into components in React
is referred to as props.
And that's represented as
Key-value pairs, or a map.
That data is immutable
to the component,
so that can only be
updated when whatever
is rendering it re-renders it.
And the component
doesn't really have
a say in updating that data.
That's very core to the
React uni-directional data
flow mental model.
Components can also have state.
This is another kind of
data that a component uses.
It's maintained by the
component itself, though.
The component itself
can mutate that data
and manage it in response to
either user input, or server
calls, or other external things.
And then together, ideally,
only props and the state
make up the rendered
output of components.
Pure components, really
idiomatic React components,
are only going to
use props and state.
And their render method, which
generates a virtual DOM which
then gets passed to React.
I talked about Render.
Render is one of the many
lifecycle methods in React.
It's actually the only
required lifecycle method.
There's a whole bunch of other
ones relating to the component
bootstrapping, or mounting
and then receiving new data.
I'm not really going
to get into those.
All we're going to
worry about is render.
Now let's talk about our
initial frustrations.
Now that we know
how React works,
we can kind of understand why
these things were frustrating.
At Workiva, when we first
started using React and Dart,
we used this library called
React-Dart on puppets React.
This is a wrapper on top of
the React JavaScript library.
What this wrapper does is
proxies lifecycle methods
in React JavaScript code, and
exposes them via Dart API.
So you can write actual
React JavaScript components
with a Dart API, and it's all
backed by the React JavaScript
library.
This is how you would
consume a component in Dart
using React-Dart.
You can see it has the same
basic structure as the JSX.
You're specifying data
as Key-value pairs,
and you're nesting components.
But we don't have
that JSX syntax.
And actually, you can do the
same thing in JavaScript.
If you don't want to
transpile your code from JSX
to JavaScript, you can just
use those component factories
directly, invoke them,
pass in the map of data,
and then nest the
components inside.
React-dart actually looks
really similar to React(JS),
and using them is very similar.
One thing to point
out though, is
that in React(JS),
you can specify
props using identifiers.
You can use identifiers
as the keys and maps.
Because in JavaScript
there's sort
of a duality between
properties and Key-value pairs,
maps and objects are
really the same thing.
In Dart, that's not the case.
In order to best
represent props and parity
behavior of being able to merge
different props maps together,
and be able to forward
certain props and not others,
React-Dart went with map to best
represent that data structure.
And I think that
was a good call.
Just know that in React-Dart,
you do have to use string keys,
whereas in JavaScript,
you could use string keys,
but you could just use
an identifier instead.
The problem with that is that we
can't get great static analysis
on these Key-value pairs.
I mean-- we can get
static analysis,
and that will tell us if we
did something syntactically
incorrect, but if we do
something semantically
incorrect, then it's not really
going to tell us ahead of time.
So what does that mean?
Here's some examples of that.
First, I've got a
custom button component
and I want to make it green.
So I'm going to set
the color prop on it
and pass in the green skin.
And it's not green.
So maybe I forgot the API,
or I misremembered it,
but color isn't the right
prop to make the button
green-- to set that skin.
And since color is not
used by the component,
it's just going to
get ignored and passed
through as an extraneous prop.
If you set that prop,
you're not really
going to get an indication
of why it's not working.
You're just going to know
that it's not working.
In this case, we would have
wanted to use the skin prop,
and then that works correctly.
A similar error is if you
mistype the skin prop,
you could have a typo
in that string key,
and it wouldn't give you an
indication that it was wrong,
and you'd think that you did it
right, but it just won't work.
So that can also be
frustrating, that you
don't get typo checking.
Another issue you can
run into is if your prop
is of the wrong type.
In this case, we
have a button, and we
want to wire up
an onClick Handler
so that when we
click it, it prints
a message to the console.
When we render that,
it actually works.
But when we go to click on
it, we get a type error.
The onClick handler expects
to have one argument
it passes through the event.
So when we give
it a function that
doesn't take any arguments,
when Dart invokes that,
we get this error.
To resolve that, we
would add an event
as a parameter to that method.
That's a case where, even after
you run and bootstrap your app,
you still won't know
that it's wrong.
You have to go and
actually click the button
to figure out that you made
a mistake, which is not
a great development experience.
Similarly, inside
of a component,
when you're rendering the
encapsulated virtual DOM,
you have to use those string
keys to access those props.
So what we ended up doing,
just as a de facto standard
inside Workiva, is we would
proxy these Key-value pairs
with these getters that we
had defined in the component.
So we'd be able to get a
little bit of static analysis
and strong typing
inside the component.
But we still didn't
have that when we
were consuming the component.
And we also still ran the risk
of mismatching it with a key
that the consumer is
actually using to render it.
We also started doing
that with state.
And we ended up with
all these getters
at the top of our
component, and it
was really hard to tell what
data was coming from state
and what data was
coming from props.
That made it really hard
to reason about the data
flow within the component.
It just made
unreadable components.
And then similarly
with state, we
had to use those string
keys, and that wasn't ideal.
So we thought, this
could be "Dartier".
So what we came up with is
a library called OverReact.
OverReact is a layer that sits
atop of React-Dart and React,
and better adapts that
API for use in Dart.
It just makes it easier
to use React and Dart.
One of the big things
that it provides
is statically declared
React UI components.
You can declare your props
and state in a static way
and get analysis
support for those.
It was built with
re-usability in mind.
Again, I'm on the
UI platform team,
and a lot of what
we were doing was
building reusable components.
So we kind of baked
in some features
to make that easier
on ourselves.
And we think that
will help others
make reusable components too.
It's also production-ready.
It's being used in a number of
Workiva apps and production,
and has been for a
while, so we're pretty
confident in it's stability.
It's also open-source, and
we just released it, I think,
a couple days ago.
So we're really excited
to get out there.
And here's the link
to this great site
our team-lead put together.
And I will re-link to that at
the end of the slideshow too.
But definitely check
out those docs.
Before I get into
the details, I really
want to communicate some
of the design decisions
that guided us while we
were building this library.
First, we wanted to utilize Dart
analyzer to its full potential.
As you saw, those
issues that you
can run into when you're
using string keys can be super
frustrating when developing.
And we weren't getting the
most out of the great Dart
tooling that was
available to us, so we
want to make sure we did that.
Second, we wanted to preserve
React principles and patterns.
We didn't want to create
a whole new framework.
We didn't want to
diverge from React.
We just wanted to take React and
make it easier to use in Dart,
so that way we
can take advantage
of all of React's
community, all of it
existing documentations and
blog posts and libraries,
and all of it's upcoming
developments and new features.
Finally, we wanted to keep
the workflow fast and simple.
We don't want a
lot of Boilerplate.
We wanted to keep declaring
components simple and easy.
So we've seen the
syntax of JSX, and we've
seen the syntax of React-Dart.
Now here is the
syntax of OverReact.
You can see it has the same
basic structure, where you're
nesting components
within each other,
and you're specifying
these Key-value pairs,
but it looks quite
a bit different.
So let's focus in on this
one specific example,
break it down, and see what's
actually going on here.
First, what happens when I'm
consuming this custom button
component, is I invoke
the button function
to create a new builder.
And then on this builder, I
can use these typed setters
to add prop Key-value pairs.
In this case, I'm setting the id
prop to the demo_button value.
I can cascade these using
Dart's "dot dot" syntax
to add as many props
as I want all in line.
Then finally, I wrap up that
expression of the builder,
and then I invoke it
with the children I want
to nest inside that component.
Then that returns a virtual
DOM instance of my button.
And that's it.
The first thing
about this syntax
is that it's such a joy
to work with in an IDE,
compared to the old
string key method.
First, if you try and use a
prop that's not available,
you're going to get a
static analysis error saying
that that prop isn't declared.
If you go to fix it,
you will actually
get an auto-complete
list of all the props
that are available along
with the doc comments.
That makes your APIs a
lot more discoverable.
A lot of developers don't
tend to learn better
by just exploring
the API's instead
of reading a bunch of docs,
so this makes it a lot easier.
You can also optionally type
these props-- these setters.
In this case, we get an error
saying that this function has
one too many arguments.
So we can just go
and add that, and not
have to wait until we click our
button to figure out that there
is a problem with it.
This Fluent interface we sought
for custom components is also
available for all of
the DOM components,
corresponding to all
of the DOM elements.
In this case, we
have a text area,
and we're setting some
DOM attribute props on it.
So we have all
the DOM components
that are available and
React-Dart, and in React.
And then we also have
all of the DOM props
that you can set
on a DOM component.
I can't remember all
of these, especially
the weird camelcasing
that some of them have,
like tabIndex is camelcased
when it's not an HTML attribute.
I can't remember that.
So having the auto-complete
is really valuable
to make sure you're not
mistyping something.
Like I showed before, this
works with custom components,
but something I
wanted to call out
is what we call
Ubiquitous DOM Props.
What we found when my team was
building all of these custom
components is there
were a set of DOM props
that consumers wanted to add
to our components all the time.
They wanted to set a custom
ID or bind some custom event
Handler.
What we ended up doing is, baked
into the base builder class,
we have props like id, tabIndex,
title, style, className,
as well as all of the
event handlers declared
on that builder so that, when
you're declaring a custom
component, all you
have to do is pass
through all of the
unconsumed props
to your rendered DOM component.
Then you'll just get all those
props passing through for free,
you don't really have
to re-declare them.
So that makes your components
a bit more reusable.
We've seen these typed
setters in action,
but how do they actually work?
The idea behind this is to
take a MapView class, which
is a Dart class that
wraps around a map
and implements a map interface.
You Can use it wherever
a map can be used,
but you can also tack on
additional functionality.
In this case, we've added
typed getters and setters
that proxy these Key-value
pairs and props and state.
So when they set the setter,
it adds that Key-value pair.
And when we access the
getter, it reads it.
We initially were
doing this by hand,
and it proved to
be kind of tedious.
We could still mistype
things, and it was a pain.
So of course we went to Code
Generation to do that for us,
right now via Pub
transformer, but I
could see it being a Bazel
build step eventually.
But to declare a
statically declared
prop, you just declare a
field, and then the transformer
or synthesizes that to
getters and setters.
And because in all of the
use cases of the props,
fields behave the same
way as getters and setters
do to the Dart analyzers,
so we're actually
able to analyze the
pre-transformed code,
and get analysis
on this, and not
have to run the generation
step, and analyze
that to verify that our
application is correct.
What does it look like to
declare a custom component,
now that we've
seen all the parts?
How does this all come together?
So first, we have a factory.
And this is a
function variable that
constructs UI props
instances, and gives us
instances of those builders.
And this is the entrypoint
to the component.
This is what your
consumers are going to use
when they're rendering them.
And we have our UI props
class, which is the builder,
and it's also a map.
It has the typed getters
and setters for convenience,
but it also can be used
wherever a map can be used.
What's nice about this is
it makes these props classes
backwards-compatible with
all the React-Dart APIs that
take Map, because it is a Map.
And then finally, we
have the component
which contains all of the
rendering and lifecycle logic.
And it also has typed
access to props and state.
So just like you use those
setters to set the props when
you're consuming
the component, you
use the getters to read
them within the component.
You'll see that we have
these annotations on all
of these classes, and that's
what the transformer uses
as hooks to define the
component declaration,
and to do that code generation.
You can see that
the UI props class
is used as generic parameters
in UIfactory and UIcomponent.
And that's what allows the
component-specific typing
to be analyzed properly.
So from that, the transformer
first takes the UIprops class
and synthesizes all those
getters and setters.
Then after that, it does some
wiring up of the UIProps class
to the factory
and the component.
There's a bunch of stuff that
needs to happen under the hood.
You have to register a component
with the React-Dart factory.
There's also some weird
stuff around constructors
that we didn't want
to put on consumers.
So basically, to
minimize Boilerplate,
we just kept the
UIProps, UIFactory,
and UIComponent declaration as
is and had the transformer do
all of the heavy lifting.
There's a big section
in our read-me
that goes into more detail
about how this actually works.
And I wish I could get into
it in this presentation,
but I don't have time.
So if you're interested,
definitely check it out.
I think it's really cool I'm
biased, though, because I'm
the one who wrote it.
So anyway, for now, just know
that you add the OverReact
transformer to your
pubspec, and then
all of the components
that you declare
will get transformed under
the hood and on the fly, too.
That's the great thing
about pub transformers.
So now that we've seen
how to build components,
let's actually do it.
Let's build a component.
What I want to build
is a counter component,
because I think
computers can probably
count better than I can.
This counter component
is going to be a button
that, when I click on it, it's
going to increment the count.
You get the gist of it.
First, I'm going to
add some rendering
logic to my component.
I'm going to add a container,
and then render a button,
and just wire up ana
onClick Handler that I'll
stub out for now.
And you can see it
does what we expect,
it's a button that
doesn't do anything.
Now let's add some props to
make this component a little bit
more configurable.
I'm going to add props
to allow the consumer
to specify the initial
count, the initial state
that the component
will start counting at,
and also the amount
that it will count
by when you click the button.
So I've just declare these
as fields in the props class,
and I've typed them as INTs
And then, in the component,
I can take the props,
and I can read
them and do props.
incrementAmount and
string interpolate
that in my button text.
And because, again,
we've used counter props
as a generic parameter, we
get typed access to props.
So anything that's declared
in props, we can just do dot
and it'll auto-complete
and analyze properly.
If we pass in a initial count of
1, then it renders as expected.
Now, since we want the
component to update itself,
we need to declare some state.
In this case, I've
made a new state class
and swapped out the base
class from UIComponent
to UIStateful component.
This allows us to add this
generic parameter so we
get typed access to this state.
In the state, we're going to
declare a currentCount field,
and that will be
a state Key-value
pair that keeps track of the
current count of the button.
So now we can consume that.
You'll see in the
container, or string
interpolating
state.currentCount--
just like we did with props--
so we can display these
or what the current count is.
Then also we are setting up the
initial state of the component.
We're initializing
the currentCount state
to the initial count
specified in props.
You'll see that I'm using
this new state method,
and this is a convenience
method that'll
just give you a new instance
of the counter state.
So that gives you
basically an empty map
that you can cascade
Key-value pairs on.
And then you can return that
to getInitialState() and React
will wire up that
initial state properly.
And finally, let's do the fun
stuff and mutate the state.
In React, the way
that you mutate state
is that you pass in
a map into setState,
and it merges that map
on the existing state,
overwriting any values.
So in this case, we're going
to call setState, create
a new map, and set
the count on it
to the current count
plus the increment.
That new count
Key-Value pair is going
to overwrite the existing one.
And then the component is going
to re-render with the updated
state.
And after that, we're all done.
Let's see if it works.
And it works.
Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
And so you'll see that we've
set initialCount to Zero
and the increment to one.
We can also configure those,
and it will work as expected.
For the sake of this
demo, I didn't include it,
but you can add default
values for these props
so that you don't have
to specify them any time.
They'll fallback
to default values.
But for the sake of simplicity,
I just left that out
Some other cool things relating
to OverReact-- OverReact
has a bunch of
other cool features.
Besides component
declaration, we've
got CSS class named building,
with a very Dart-like API,
similar to the classNames
utility bundled with React(JS),
but it's got one more
feature that it doesn't have.
We got typed checking.
That's something that wasn't
possible in React-Dart,
but is possible in
JavaScript-- being
able to tell whether
a VDOM instance is
a type of a certain component
that's useful for conditionally
rendering passed-in children,
and also generic callback
chaining.
Something I also wanted
to call out is testing.
With React-Dart, there
is a wrapper currently
for ReactTestUtils, which is
a test utility suite bundled
with a React that allows you
to simulate events, and query
for different components,
and get data about them.
So that all works with
React-Dart, and with OverReact.
But we do have a set
OverReact test utilities
that we've made to make that
process a little bit easier,
and add some stuff that
ReactTestUtils doesn't have.
I know that that's coming
soon, but in the meantime,
you can still test with this
using just React-Dart test
utils.
I couldn't come all
this way to Germany
without mentioning some
other Workiva packages.,
but these really are
relevant to OverReact.
One of them is w_flux,
which implements
the uni-directional
data flow model that was
inspired by Flux and RefluxJS.
We use this a lot internally
to manage the data flow
within our apps.
And it integrates
great with OverReact.
There's actually a flux
UIComponent in OverReact
that automatically
declares actions and store.
And when the store triggers,
it will automatically
re-render your component, so
that's very well integrated.
We also used dart_dev to
run our tests and coverage,
and that makes it easier.
We use that in OverReact.
There's a bunch more packages
at workiva.github.io.
We love to open-source
stuff when we can,
give back to the community.
So expect to see
more at that site.
So again, here's the link to the
beautiful docs site, our repo.
If you have any questions
about any of this,
feel free to come grab
me after this talk,
or open up a GitHub issue.
We're very responsive.
If there's something
that you don't like,
or if you have an idea, idea
for an improvement, a bug,
just file a GitHub issue.
We'll be really
responsive on that.
And if you want a
direct line, there
is my email, or my team's email.
And give React and Dart a shot.
Thank you.